first principles is kind of a physics
way of looking at the world you boil
things down to the most fundamental
truths and and say okay what do we sure
is true and then reason up from there
somebody could say in fact people do
that battery packs are really expensive
and that's just the way they'll always
be because that's the way they've been
in the past no that's that's pretty dumb
if you apply that reasoning to anything
new you wouldn't be able to ever get to
that new thing so the first principles
would be to say okay what are the
material constituents to the batteries
what is the spot market value of the
material constituents so you can say
okay it's got cobalt nickel aluminum
carbon and some polymers for separation
and steel can if we bought that in
london metal exchange what would each of
those things cost like oh it's like $80
per kilowatt hour so clearly you just
need to think of clever ways to take
those materials and combine them into
the shape of a battery cell and you can
have batteries that are much much
cheaper than anyone realizes